to host the next segment of the show
it's my pleasure to introduce a most
distinguished actor who's thrilled and
delighted all of us in many motion
pictures this year he is one of the
Academy nominees in the Best Actor
category ladies and gentlemen mr.
Michael king
if it weren't for an American film the
Caine Mutiny the bloke standing before
you now would still be called Moorish
Joseph Michael White in the old tent
road where I was born the name didn't
matter because what we called each other
would blow the tube out of your telly I
was left on my own and after I did a few
things I was supposed to do and a few
things I wasn't supposed to do I used to
sneak in the cinema and they didn't make
taps out of me I used to sneak in the
side entrance but I learned how to wear
a trench coat from bogey your white tie
from Fred and shades from Harold Lloyd
which brings me right into the next
award to present it a lady whom you saw
on the covers of Vogue before you saw
her in cabaret and whose hems were
basted by her grandmother a little
French seamstress named Elsa
Schiaparelli miss Marisa Berenson
the bridge is supposed to say and winter
is of course and with her is a man with
the problem me
every October somebody selects the 10
best-dressed men of the year and in
November somebody else selects the 10
worst dress men of the year my problem
is I made both lists tell me the truth
which list would you put me on very now
very avant-garde and therefore out out
how can I be in and out in the same suit
that little French seamstress my
grandmother explained it in fashion the
only thing certain is is what's in today
is out tomorrow the dough thrown away
it'll be in again the day after the
nominees tonight prove that well queue
for the best achievement in costume
design the nominees are travel with my
aunt
Antony Park
the Godfather Anna Hill Johnstone the
Poseidon Adventure Paul's at stupa [ __ ]
Lady Sings the Blues Bob Mackie reggae
and Norma Koch
young Winston Antony Mendelson
and the winner is the winner is Anthony
Paul for travels with my arms accept the
new award for Anthony
the director
as the Powell is presently working in
London and I accept it with his
gratitude and I must say as the director
he was an enormous help so I'm very
grateful to him myself
thank you